good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Thursday hope everyone's having a great
day speaking of greatness let me
introduce you
to the greatest
mom
podcast host sister friend Jacqui hey
Jax how you doing this is so sweet of
you to say McClure to what do I owe the
pleasure what do you want what do you
need anything
nothing I just wanted to Express
gratitude maybe it's because I'm coming
off of like kind of my Barbara Walters
moment yesterday right with with someone
who's very into you know the the
positivity and like energy space and my
interview with our guests yesterday like
definitely changed my life and this if
this is what we have in return for your
interview just like this positive
heaping praise upon others Claude like
you should do it every day
100 I I feel so annoying like I hate to
be I mean the game is entering and
carrying you guys do that but
um and I tried to get the episode to
release early but it has to release at
the end of the month so I'm just gonna
keep talking about it but we'll tell you
guys soon I have another interview today
with someone really fun and exciting
like yesterday's was kind of serious
very like you know mental health
oriented and today's is gonna be like
fun and fresh
um but yeah that's kind of like why I'm
feeling stunning why are you feeling
stunning I'm feeling stunning because
you just you know talked me up and that
was really inspiring for me and it's
been a very good productive morning over
here we have a great day full of stories
it's actually our last show of the week
which is always Bittersweet bitter
because I'm gonna miss you I'm gonna
miss the toaster is sweet because well
all everything else
um
but uh it's good to wrap up the week get
through the stories Claudia texted me
this morning begging
I didn't beg and her hands and knees I
didn't beg for us to talk about
Harry Prince Harry sorry Prince Harry
Windsor it's confusing with my son it is
because I don't have to beg to talk
about the real Prince Harry
um I didn't beg that's what screenshots
are for I said I think we can do a story
today about Harry because as much as
like I've tried to avoid it and I do
feel good like I was getting so fatigued
there is so much to discuss we can
discuss it I didn't want to like talk
about it and my energy just to be like
so like not even like so dismissive of
it you know because I'm so over it yeah
that's not productive podcasting
no and it's not fun like when I'm like I
hate you bye you know yeah yeah that's
not a conversation
so we are going to talk a little bit
about it today
um he's really just my God
any shred of dignity or respect or
um
like regal-ness that he had in my in my
eyes is completely gone no he is a
commoner through and through but
actually it's an insult to commoners
because I do not think most commenters
would do what he's doing
um in so many different ways like the
Airing the family drama like people's
personal secrets people's private
conversations and it's like for what
for what
so we'll get into all of that before we
do this being our last show of the week
we have to catch up with our La
correspondent we do how is the West
Coast treating you would you say it's
the best coast
I definitely would not say that and I
think people who say that are deeply
unwell it's a decent Coast you know
that's what I would say do you think the
east coast is the best coast
100 well I think if we're comparing all
coasts like probably the Amalfi Coast is
the best one Amalfi Coast greater than
west coast East Coast
but if we're keeping it national no I'm
definitely an East Coast girl the Sun
finally came out it stopped raining
which has been nice
um and last night I've been just like
you know trying to be productive while
I'm here be social see people but last
night I stayed in and I actually watched
a TV show that I've never seen that
people are obsessed with that I actually
think you would love because when we
were talking yesterday about how you
want to start watching Abbott Elementary
for you know these reasons I also um
when I was watching the show last night
I was like this could be a Content upper
can I guess what it is
yeah Jenny in Georgia
no okay I give up no
it is The Mindy Project hmm
it's I feel like it's a show that has
this cult following I'm always seeing
like you know edits on Tick Tock I've
never seen one shred of it Ben's sister
loves it so when we my TV has uh Netflix
at the hotel praise be like also all
hotels should have Netflix and I was
just looking for something mindless to
watch and like something good and me and
Ben watched like 10 episodes last night
it's so good the writing is so funny and
I'm kind of just like in my Mindy Kaling
era recently and that reminds me I have
this like running list of like dream
toast guests and outside of the obvious
ones like Taylor and Kim you know yeah
um Taylor and Kim together
iconic so I am going to add Mindy Kaling
to that because she is kind of
everything yeah that's very good maybe
next time on my list maybe next time
with a little more notice you could get
her in La maybe yeah okay let me hear
the list
Kiki Palmer okay
RuPaul okay
Kelly Clarkson of course
Kim Chloe Taylor the them and now Mindy
Kaling it's a short it's a short list
yeah no because this is like
highest hopes ideal like random
is that just your list like should I be
making my own list would you like to
partner on a list yeah we could do a
collab list but usually I housed all the
list so this is going to be hard for me
to relinquish control I feel like I
should house it because then that way
you could just like spew it and I'll
write it down no and
um my phone just fell on the floor so
I'm not bending down to pick it up also
make your own list you could like notes
allows you to collab with others on
notes I know but my my list of Ideal
guests isn't just that I use lit like
notes for multiple things like
underneath it is this list that I have
for a spritz event we're coming up and
then I think underneath it is like some
questions I had for the guests yesterday
like oh oh multiple notes I don't like
to waste paper oh I use a fresh note for
everything okay I'm trying to remember
your list and then I will just add on to
it I'm honestly not even adding like Kim
and Taylor like duh
right you know this is like people who I
always forget that I'm obsessed with
yeah yeah yeah okay so I'm gonna add
that it was Josh Palmer
Kiki Palmer RuPaul Kelly Clarkson Andy
Kaling Kim Taylor yes
um Josh Groban is a dream guest of mine
um Guy Fieri I would love to chat with
him and pick his brain
Elon dream guest and possible because he
podcasts
he does podcasts a lot of people thought
when I was referencing um the guest
yesterday I posted a tick tock that I
just recorded this amazing interview
with someone you know who's really
impressive and who you wouldn't expect
to come on the toast and it was a man
and the number one guess was Elon Musk
and I love that people have that much
faith in us like don't get me wrong the
toast is literally huge but like we're
not that huge you know yeah but like
even though Elon is by far the biggest
person on this list I actually think
he's the person with the biggest chance
of we could actually get him on because
he goes on podcasts he's like a man of
the people
and we are a show of the people
and it's really important that people
don't forget and I'm including myself
because I'm constantly forgetting that I
actually met Elon Musk and he told me he
liked my blog like five years ago
um so like there's a connection there so
you should get on your blog and do a
call out to Elon because he obviously
checks it every day checks it daily like
he definitely checks it daily and I
definitely could use my platform for
good you could and you should you could
and I will uh anyone else shall we
continue on the list
anyone else
I would have loved to have Queen
Elizabeth the second rip did she ever do
any podcasts before her passing no she
did a lot of radio
so classy Queen the same but different
we could have lied and said we haven't a
big American radio show yeah I don't
think she wants to be a saxophone I
don't think she wants to be on big
American radio though
no definitely she's probably like missed
opportunity sure
that's what you would say
um I also feel like Keke Palmer coming
on the toast like now that she's
pregnant like I feel like she would do
it like we're kind of like oh yeah
podcast Kiki Palmer would be a great
guest and and she's so toasty and we're
so kinky like that honestly we should
just get the the wheels turning on that
yeah I think so too and I think we would
like like to see Kiki Palmer in real
life in action would be probably one of
the greatest joys of my life like I
don't think there's a person on the
planet who was naturally more funny than
Keke Palmer I know but she's not even
trying but it would also be a hard
interview for you because like you'd
really have to just not talk so much
because we're just like listening and
I'm observing
okay so I actually was gonna say I
actually think it would be easy for me
because I would not want to talk like I
actually just want to listen it's like
I'm watching a movie okay and you think
that you could do it
yeah
okay that's beautiful you should have
seen me yesterday during this interview
so quiet like I was enjoying my absolute
hardness not to like jump in you know
good that's that's good for me but you
also like it's hard for me it's just
it's a dance like I feel like people
always like to complain about other
podcasts not ours that like that person
was talking over the guest a lot you
know what I mean and it's like yeah that
is annoying when people do that but you
also have to keep the conversation going
so it's great it's a line that you have
to walk because especially with podcast
interviews they're interviews but
they're they're more so conversations
yeah the conversation requires two
people yeah it's not just a one-way
street right that's why we love
conversation
I love conversation especially when I'm
the one bulldozing it
okay we'll keep this list open as we
talk about people like we'll talk about
whether or not they deserve to be on
this list
no and you know what if somebody steps
out of bounds or acts you know like a
fool they might be removed from the list
so true and that would be devastating
for them like everything changes when
you're removed from the list
so we're keeping Hollywood in check with
our list we're always keeping Hollywood
in check we're just like these watchdogs
were these like checkers
because you want to know why Hollywood
is playing chess and we're playing
checkers and that's embarrassing for us
yeah that means we're dumb and stupid
yeah and simple-minded
simple minded oh my God also so
yesterday after my interview I went to
the good influences podcast hosted by
like Harley Aaron Matt King and Mike
um and I just liked their podcast and I
was really excited to do it and we had
like a really great conversation and I
was referencing Katie from Sex in the
City like simple girls versus like crazy
girls and how I'm not you know I'm a
cookie Katie and when I tell you not one
person knew the reference and that was
like the first time in recent memory
I've actually felt like embarrassed
that's really sad I wasn't expecting a
sad tale from like your time on the good
influences podcast I thought you're
gonna talk about like what great time
you have which I'm sure you did which
I'm sure you did but you just like have
to tell us about the one Awkward Moment
no it was great and then like I'm just
so used to talking to you who knows
every single movie TV show book
reference that I'm gonna spew on the
show so I didn't I didn't even say with
explanation I just said it like assuming
everybody would know what I was talking
about I was like I'm like a Katie with
curly hair and they're like Claudia are
you okay
they're like this girl's having a
seizure I'm developed a stutter I'm like
you guys don't know Katie with the curly
hair they're like I thought for sure
Carly and Aaron would know but not like
Matt and Mike nobody knew what I was
talking about and then I really realized
how like what we do is so insular
yeah it is it must be hard to like go
out into the real world you know you're
like someone who's been homeschooled and
now you're going to North Shore High
School with Regina George
I'm literally Jacob Tremblay you're
Katie Herron
I'm Katie Herron yeah yeah I I wouldn't
say you're Jacob chamberlay in the room
like that's extremely extreme
oh have I not made that abundantly clear
to you like I'm the most extreme in the
world like that's so me that's so you I
guess that makes me Brie Larson
um I guess in room
no I know but
I guess actually I would be Brie Larson
in room because like she's extreme at
the end you know like she can't handle
it no but I feel like I feel like you'll
adapt better out in the world
that I would say I think
actually I do agree with that
but the way I've seen room once and I
find myself applying room to everyday
life like that movie do other people
like regard that movie as much as we do
like I think it's like literally the
most important piece of art that's ever
come out of Hollywood yeah
it was [ __ ] crazy you only need to
see it once anyone who watches it more
than once is like Twisted problematic
like watches it for actual entertainment
for pleasure oh
sick
well we have an amazing show anything
else you want to catch up on like have
you driven anywhere recently that you
want to talk about no actually
um oh but I guess I'll use the time to
make a PSA because I went to the doctor
yesterday I went to the dermatologist to
get a full body check all as well but
just wanted to use it as a reminder for
everyone else because honestly like it
took for me like a few celebs reminding
us for me to be like okay I'll get my
ass there
um so if you're listening and like
you've been putting it off uh just go it
was totally fine but um Zach had the car
so I did have to call an Uber and I got
that driver that I always get um we're
on a first neighbors basis her name's
Olivia and she's a really big fan so it
was really sweet
um that's cool to ride with her yeah
that's cool it's nice to like meet you
know toasters in everyday life toasters
in the wild
um and then are so important they are so
important and then I podcasted with my
Uber driver Olivia
um we just like took questions about
like Mom life Suburban life it was
really fun we podcasted from Olivia's
car it wasn't moving
um we just like couldn't get to a quiet
place in her house and it was really
funny and we're just talking about you
know like this current stage that the
kids are in and what the highs and lows
are
so cute moms for life so what's up on
patreon now patreon.com the toast
the dust Yes siree uh did you have
anything else that you wanted to share
no relatively low-key just like
productive busy day happy to be back
here sad it's the last episode of the
week but excited that by the next
episode like I will be home I like I'm
having a great time and I'm really glad
I came like I feel like it's been a
really productive trip especially like
after yesterday went so well like I just
like that's really what I was here for
so I feel really good and productive but
like I'm so ready to go home yeah and
I'm sure I hate to bring this up but I'm
sure you missed Theo
it's so upsetting like
yeah yeah yeah
okay we'll leave it at that well Strife
sends his love my angel boy
give my angel boy so much of my love
telling me as my whole heart except for
the parts that Theo has of course and he
understands completely like he's
understanding good good because it's a
heart you got
so without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
do need to know
you didn't do d
you didn't do do need to know that
today's episode is also brought to you
by the perfect bar looking for a protein
bar that actually tastes good well look
no further than the perfect bar with
their lineup of fresh from the fridge
protein bars perfect bar is exactly what
you've been looking for no chalky
artificial aftertaste here they're made
with with freshly ground nut butter
organic honey and 20 organic superfoods
perfect bar has a variety of products
like protein bars little snack size bars
too that are also good and good for you
you'll be sure to find something you
love my favorite is definitely the dark
chocolate chip peanut butter with sea
salt
um it's so delicious it's become my
go-to snack I have them in the fridge at
my hotel I love that perfect bars are
kept in the fridge it really like
reinforces that their products are made
with really fresh really healthy
ingredients and it's just a feel-good
snack that's going to keep you
full all day long when you're doing
podcast podcasts meeting meeting and
that's what I have today
um they have a cookie dough texture it's
creamy and full of flavor unlike any
other bars out there they now come in
the snack size which is packed up to six
grams of proteins and 150 calories so a
little goes a long way with these it is
the perfect thing to throw in your purse
for a busy day you will feel full you
will feel satiated you will feel
energized perfect bars knows that it'll
be Love At First Bite so for a limited
time they're offering you a chance to
try their refrigerated protein bars for
free here's how it works sign up for
email or text and upload a picture of
your receipt from your local grocery
store and they'll reimburse you for the
cost of one bar it'll go directly into
your venmo or PayPal account which is
pretty cool I've heard so much feedback
from so many of our listeners that
they've done this already and that they
love it and it's just like great to get
like free snacks and they love the pro
the perfect bar so again
all you have to do is go to perfect
snacks.com toast to get that free
perfect bar that's perfect snacks.com
toast to get that free perfect bar today
happy snacking enjoy your snack and then
enjoy a free one too this is what's
better than that that just made me
hungry I wish I brought one up here with
me and then I could have eaten it during
the ad and no one could complain because
I would be doing like product placement
because you were doing your job yeah
our first story Prince Harold Harry
Windsor is he's been Unchained
temporarily making audiences around the
world cringe with some of the excerpts
from his novel including one bit that is
particularly harrowing when you listen
as an audiobook so I told you like him
reading it as an audiobook I've seen so
many Clips online is another level of
like invasiveness in my mind it's so
bizarre it's so bizarre and I also feel
like he definitely wrote this book he
worked with a co-author
um but I could see if you know
if he never read the whole finished book
you know he like gave his stories then
they worked on specific passages
together and then the co-author put it
all together and like it's possible he
didn't read everything
um but he read the audiobook which means
he read the whole ass book and he
decided to leave this part in so uh
audiobook listeners are left feeling
horrified as Prince Harry says he felt
like his mother was right there in the
room as he applied the Elizabeth Arden
cream she loved to his fraught spitting
penis Prince Harry has left readers
wincing with his account of applying
Elizabeth art and cream used by his late
mother
to his frostbitten penis in the passage
he recalls that his late mother Princess
Diana used to apply the cream to her
lips he says quote to her lips and says
the smell of the product made him feel
like his mother was right there in the
room before he applied the cream to his
penis he recounts how a friend
recommended he used the product on the
injured area after he returned from a
trip to the North Pole before Prince
William's wedding this is when he tells
us he had a frostbitten penis from the
trip that he had it Willy's wedding his
frostbitten Willy for Willie's wedding
uh and a friend suggested Elizabeth
Arden cream for his nether region then
he says that's the cream my mom used he
cracks it open I'm sorry that's the
cream my mom used on her lips he cracks
it open she's in there with in the room
with him with the smell and he applies
it to his penis people are calling the
book a quote Freudian nightmare
you know it's definitely giving like
some Hamlet Vibes
um I don't know why this entire Saga was
necessary to include was Hamlet the one
in love with his mother
that's Oedipus
no I feel like it was in the book I mean
they all are if we're being honest
okay no like
I'm telling you tablet let me Google it
Hamlet Mother Love
oh wait yeah wait Hamlet does love his
mother he shows this by staying behind
when she asks him to instead of going
back to school checking in on her trying
to keep her out of his plans to kill
Claudius
and not completely shutting her or
hating her from moving on from his
father so quickly oh so it's like
they're they're saying Hamlet loves his
mother he doesn't hate her not like he
has this uh Freudian love for her
okay whatever like English was not my
subject still isn't even my language
um
so I don't really understand why this
particular personal anecdote like was
necessary for the book and then I don't
really understand why anyone around him
would have read this passage and not
just like alerted him to the fact like
it was [ __ ] weird and
once again I'm finding really nothing in
this book to be of value or worth
telling in the sense that like
everything that they really wanted to
share about leaving I feel like they
have done
so I'm not understanding the purpose of
this book whatsoever yeah and
I don't know I imagine the royal family
is freaking out the headlines say
there's a war room to deal with the book
but like to me this is amazing press for
the royal family like they these Megan
and Harry have been kind of a thorn in
their side for since they left in 2020
and now he is digging his own grave and
I would just sit back and watch because
like the American people are turning on
him and that's really where his biggest
contingency of support was coming from
um
so I don't I can't I hope they're not
thinking of this as like a crisis
because it's really not like he's doing
them a favor by really just like writing
himself out of embarrassing himself yeah
like and just nobody I think people for
a while could relate to his feelings of
you know putting his wife first and his
children first and and not wanting
history to repeat itself but I don't
think a lot of people can relate to
what he's doing and sharing all of these
not even the penising if he wants to
talk about his penis like it's his penis
to talk about but like stuff about
William and Kate stuff about his dad
stuff about Camilla I think like he
calls like there's like a lot of evil
stepmother stuff in there honestly the
Camilla stuff to me is like the least
interesting so I I don't even know what
he actually I don't actually
I find Harry's take on Camilla I watched
an interview he did really kind of
batching her I find his take on Camilla
to be the most hypocritical because if
anything if anyone should understand
like the position his dad was in like
being forced to marry not being able to
marry the woman he loved because she was
like you know divorced or not considered
appropriate like if anyone should
understand that it should be Harry and
how he was so lucky to have been given
the opportunity to marry someone he
loves because look at what happened to
his dad and his mom because his dad was
just not allowed from the get to marry
someone he loved I found his comments on
Camilla to be the most hypocritical
because if anyone should understand it's
Harry yes no but he can't because also
like he's his his like Diana's boy like
he's always gonna see it from the lens
of Diana who who hates Camilla who hates
Charles like they they and from her
perspective it's like okay they always
loved each other and then they brought
Diana in it's just like
they used her a placeholder yes so the
Harry sees it that way too he doesn't
see like this sacrifice that his dad
made I don't think he has like a ton of
reverence for his dad
well that's just immaturity but it's
like he can't even see it's like what we
talked about yesterday's self-awareness
he can't even see the similarities
between their experiences but just that
Harry hat well one being the spare Harry
having the
privilege of being able to make his own
choice
right and really like no one told him no
when he wanted to marry Megan and his
dad was told no so many times and like
look at what it did to everyone involved
right and but it doesn't seem like he
has compassion for that again I didn't
read the book maybe the compassion just
didn't make the headlines
are you going to read the book now no
one because it's all um out there
um all the highlights anything that's
really interesting is already out there
and I I got the point you know I feel
like if anything it makes it I'm very
interested like in the modern history of
the winter so I might read that book The
Palace papers I was actually about to
start it but then I saw it was like 800
pages and I was like I just can't do
this right now
um but I just
I don't know what's next for the like I
feel like I mean I wonder how Megan
feels because like she yeah she's not
yes really sullied by this book like
Harry is self-sullying completely but
like yeah where does she go from here
because nobody wants to hear from him
anymore
how is she going to like she's the only
one who could really write their ship
now I think she still has you know
positive Q scores and and people still
like her
but not so much him
no I was thinking the same thing like
what are Megan's thoughts on this
because she's like you know
we haven't heard from her there's been
like no press about her the book is
really about Harry and his experience
and to be honest I just find like so
much of what he's been writing to be so
hypocritical like of course the Camilla
stuff but then also I don't know
publishing like word for word text
message exchanges between Harry between
Megan and Kate is so so invasive that's
like what they that's what they hate
that the Daily Mail did yeah that's what
they sued for because when the Daily
Mail published letters that Megan had
written to her family like that is an
invasion of privacy that is illegal like
she was right and justified in suing the
Daily Mail so how you can turn around
and publish someone else's conversations
without their consent like that's to me
like you're only interested in what
benefits you like you don't actually
care about the truth because that's so
[ __ ] up in my opinion yeah I also
think that this book did not get
published without Megan's
approval too like like one I think a
wife would read a husband's book too
there's so much so much at stake and and
you know she has a I think a good sense
of judgment in terms of like what's
going to play well with the public
um so maybe they just didn't see it
coming maybe they they've gotten so much
praise heaped upon them for the last two
years maybe they really didn't think
they could go wrong and that people
would lap up even more whatever more is
he wants to share and call it instead of
it being like over sharing maybe they
they thought we would think it was Brave
you know no you're right like America
has embraced them to the point where
like you know if you criticize anything
they do you're just like a hater and I
do think that's sort of like unbridled
like Universal acceptance has maybe made
them a little uh cocky yeah
yeah totally right
but I don't think they expected in a
million years for people to really start
to get so annoyed by them so quickly
like there was a surgeons of like you
know especially for Harry like of Harry
hatred from the documentary and I think
the book is just Next Level I don't
think anybody's reading this book and
and sobbing oh my God the truth like
it's not I don't think it's what what he
thought was gonna happen yeah so
I think after this they will have some
quiet time I I would but as you love to
remind me they have two more books right
but it could be anything it could be
children's book it could be fiction you
know he could write like a war novel or
something
who knows what his interests are
it could be a coffee table book there's
a lot of books shall I count all the
genres would it change your opinion of
him if he wrote a smut book
a good one a good one about like you
know similar did you ever read red white
and royal blue
no oh my God you should I know it's like
Royal smut
I know
so I think that's the only way he could
recommended this around it's so funny I
recommend that book to everyone that's
so funny I try not to recognize
especially books I haven't read
especially
no because it has a it has gay
characters yes it's a gay smut
so I always recommend it's my gay
friends and they love it yeah I'm like
yeah I pretend like I read it I'm like
it's so good right yeah I guess I would
do that about a book that like Dana
highly recommended to me I would like
there's this book the push that like
everyone said it's really serious like I
haven't read it but I know it's really
good oh that's so Twilight
push totally okay Harry that's your next
PR move a little smut but you should
talk to Colleen Hoover if she should go
write your next book
uh even though she's in some trouble of
her own
yes we will that's a great segue it is a
great segue if we can put a lid on this
I guess for now yeah put a lid like
seriously and and I mean this like with
love in my heart Harry shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up and go to bed
yeah but I think also he's reached That
Celebrity Echelon where it's like they
all are very like self-congratulatory
they don't really realize that like
people [ __ ] hate them you know he's
going on like Stephen Colbert and then
Steven's like and they they're doing all
their bits and like there's no one
around I don't think they they probably
like don't even look at tweets because
they just assume it's all haters and
they just like live in this bubble like
I don't think he even knows that
feelings have changed
you know what you're so right that's
such a danger of celebrity and I find
like when celebrities have people around
them who are just like you know on the
payroll and work for them like they're
Posse it really leads to a level of
delusion and so many of like the most
grounded celebrities are people that
have like childhood friends family
around them who can tell them like [ __ ]
you look stupid yeah and you need to I
don't think it's healthy to read like
everything that people think about you
but if your business is being a public
figure like you do need to take the
temperature sometimes no you need
someone you need a temperature taker it
doesn't have to be you yeah an honest
temperature taker who's like listen
we're chilly today
mm-hmm we need to heat things up with
some smut
right oh
okay well let's get into our next story
which is going to bump to number two
some Colleen Hoover news she is in a
little bit of hot water she's been um
dubbed as quote tone deaf for a coloring
book inspired by her novel about
domestic violence it will not be
published after all so Colleen announced
on Tuesday that she was publishing a
coloring book inspired by her book it
ends with us which I think is her
biggest book of all of her books the
novel is largely about domestic violence
violence leading many to criticize the
coloring book
on Wednesday Colleen's publisher
announced the project would not move
forward so Colleen had said
um
I'm one of the adult coloring books
biggest industry consumers so to have
one of my books turned into a coloring
book is a dream I'm so excited for this
releases April 4th 2023 beautifully
illustrated by Emma Taylor but then
social media users were not excited as
the author initially was about the
project many critical a decision to turn
a novel um into a coloring book due to a
subject matter it's about domestic
violence both the main character and a
mother faced domestic violence in the
story
um
when you put it like that yeah here's
the thing it's definitely weird like
first of all
it's weird like and that and the fact
that the for that this idea made it from
like the ideation stage all the way to
publication without anyone being like is
this weird is definitely cause for
concern
But ultimately like there were people
who were excited about this I just think
with this like backlash culture like if
you think it's weird like just don't buy
it you know yeah I also feel like I can
understand how an idea like this you
know comes to be this is a massively
popular book it's being turned into a
movie like how do we monetize it in a
way that makes sense with Colleen and
her brand and I'm sure they threw a lot
a lot of ideas I'm sure a lot of the
ideas when you think about the fact that
it's a book about domestic violence a
lot of the ideas then probably don't
work but I don't think they were
thinking about the book as a book about
domestic violence honestly I think they
were thinking of it as you know a
Colleen Hoover love story
yeah and when you look at the book from
the lens of books one and two like the
whole series it is a love story
but when you think of it through the
lens of book number one and if you
haven't read it just this is a spoiler
alert like there is no love story like
you actually the book ends no and the
book ends and her and Alice just
reconnect on the street they don't fall
in love they fall in love in the second
book for sure but it's like you know
that she's gonna be with Alice and like
the after everything that they've been
through that they're gonna be together
yeah but like in the actual book they
are not together yeah
I don't know if someone
brought this to me and said like we're
gonna do a coloring book about it ends
with us it's so popular and people want
like more [ __ ] to do with it I'd be like
okay cool it would not register for me
no it definitely like takes a minute to
like sit like and something about
coloring is very childish and and I
think that's why the adult coloring
space is so popular it's like
reconnecting with your childhood and
it's very calming and it helps with
anxiety so in a lot of ways like it kind
of does make sense you know like
I get why it's weird like I agree that
it's weird I don't know if they had to
you know halt the whole thing like if
you don't like it don't buy it like you
don't have to write a tweet about why
you think it's dumb like just don't buy
it yeah
yeah
so
like I think coloring you know what
actually I can make the argument that
that I can make the argument actually
that that it's on a terrible that it
could be healing
adult coloring is very much like a
healing thing it reduces anxiety it's an
escapism and so I actually could see
someone thinking this is a good idea
that's not me saying I think it's a good
idea but I'm saying I could see someone
thinking it's a good idea so I think
there were probably there was probably a
market for this and there was probably
people who didn't want it and people
don't want it you literally no one's
holding a gun to your head you don't
have to buy it the more we talk about it
like the more I think it's kind of
innocuous
no the more I think it's like not the
worst idea in the world no and I could
unders this isn't something to me where
it's like this pass through tens of
people and nobody noticed like I would
have been one of those people like to be
honest
totally
and no like the more we talk through it
like I imagine the scenes that we would
be coloring wouldn't be or not you know
it'd be Lily and coloring in Lily's
bruises
Lily in the flower shop
right Lily's Garden at her house yeah
what else Lily see it there's a lot of
like
every scene is kind of stained
no for sure for sure but that's but
that's also like the beauty of the book
it's like I and what I really loved
about the book when I first read it is
that it's so
it's so accurately took you through the
emotions of what it's like to be Lily
yeah like falling in love it's so great
did he just put his hands on me no he
couldn't have like you really go through
the emotional stages every chapter so
and you also go through the cycle of
like being a daughter of of that type of
situation and wanting to break the cycle
so I don't know I I don't think it's the
worst idea no
I don't think it is either
I didn't know that was going to be it's
not happening that's I didn't know that
was going to be where I landed here
which is like bring it back
no me too I was ready to be like this
dumb [ __ ] I'm I'm gonna be part of the
contingency that is going to go against
the backlashers I'm going to give
backlash to the backlashers
they need it yeah they do and maybe
since the publishing house is really
just [ __ ] fickle then they'll hear
our movement right and then they'll be
like it's back
no to be honest I really feel like the
decision to not move forward with it was
entirely Colleen's like Colleen is the
biggest author of our time right now
like what Colleen says goes and she
released a statement on her Instagram
being like we announced this project I
immediately got feedback from you guys
that it wasn't the vibe it was not
appropriate we're not doing it anymore
it sounds like she just really like
respects what her listeners I mean what
her readers think and decided not to
move forward for that reason
which I understand
the The Reflex to do that I do
so so do I of course but obviously she
said she's a huge fan of adult coloring
books she's like a huge patron of their
you know a huge consumer this was
obviously something that like she
thought of on her own and like was
really excited about
and and it was written for her
yeah
congrats
you played yourself
now we don't get a coloring book
and who suffers
the colorers
constantly getting shafted
are you ready for our next story which
is some more business news
um in a week of trending Beauty business
news it's not looking good yes no
Sephora is dropping the beauty lines of
tick tock Stars Addison Ray and Hiram
Yarbrough the Hiram thing is crazy it
looks like the beauty products have two
popular influencers Addison Ray and
Hiram Yarbrough might no longer be
available in the malls of America
Insider has confirmed a well-connected
Industry Source that Sephora will be
pulling Addison Ray's item Beauty and
Hiram Yarborough selfless by Hiram from
its shelves while item products are
still available to purchase on the
beauty giant site products from selfless
are nowhere to be found
quote well let's talk about selfless
first can I give you background I feel
like yes I don't know anything
okay so skincare by Hiram was this tick
tocker um selfless by Hiram
well no Hiram skincare by Hiram was his
name oh okay okay
and he used to like duet people who did
their skincare routine and like either
praise them or tell them what products
were bad and people would like literally
do their skincare and be like Hiram
please rate me and he would talk about
like why you know certain products don't
have great ingredients and this one has
fragrance like he was really teaching
people about skin care and he kind of
popped off like really he had I don't
know how many followers but like a ton
he was all over my free page and I
didn't even follow him
and then
um he released his own skincare line
with Sephora and it was like such a good
idea on Sephora's part and when I tell
you right after I heard about the launch
I never saw a video of Hiram ever again
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened
um then there was like a little bit of
controversy because Hiram is not like a
licensed dermatologist I don't even
think he's a licensed esthetician so it
was like well why are we listening to
Hiram like what's your background yeah
but it's like why were we listening to
Hiram to begin with like no that was the
question like he sounded like he knew
what he was talking about but then I
think when you're gonna actually get
into the space and like sell products to
people like you definitely need to have
some sort of like backing medically in
order for people to really trust you yes
in order for people to trust you for
sure
that is [ __ ] weird I've never even
heard of him so that just shows you like
how big or small he might be you know I
was not surprised I literally forgot
that he got a skincare line I was not
surprised when they announced that it
was being canceled honestly I didn't
even know it was still on the shelves I
didn't even know he was still on Tick
Tock I don't know what happened to him
it's like literally he became so
successful and then whether it was the
algorithm or whatever he literally
disappeared from the face of my phone
wow well he put out a statement to
Insider saying due to changes in
Direction and Retail adjustments
selfless by Hiram products have been
winding down at Sephora so this goes
back to what we were saying like this
doesn't mean that influencers are no
longer influential but like it changes
literally every five minutes so it
doesn't make sense to really invest in a
standalone brand for an influencer who
is not
tested and hasn't stood the test of time
yeah and there's no when someone's been
famous for five minutes there is no way
to know which of all these five-minute
Fame people are going to be famous for
10 15 20 Etc so it doesn't make sense to
like invest in them so bigly but but
like a capsule collection what about a
capsule collection
well so I also was surprised at the
Addison of it all because you know we
were talking earlier this week Tick Tock
is very much like the Hub of beauty
trends things go viral on Tick Tock and
they really make a difference in in what
sells in the beauty space and a lot of
Addison's products have gone viral a lot
of people have reviewed her products
very positively it's definitely not a
brand for everyone but it's there are
some like bomb products on there and I
thought it was doing relatively well I
think item beauty is not as successful
as it should have could have or would
have been because something is going on
with Addison like Addison is not
invested in being a an influencer right
now like she if you I follow her on
Instagram so I don't know what she does
on Tick Tock but she posts like the bare
minimum she posts pictures that could
have been taken any time any place like
we're not I don't feel like I'm keeping
up with her I don't feel like she's
bringing me into her life which she used
to do so something's changed with
Addison where like she has consciously
taken a step back from social media I
feel like
if she had wanted item to be more of a
success like it would have been but her
priorities are elsewhere right now I
don't know what it is maybe it's like
she has a lot going on with her family
maybe she had a taste of all this Fame
and like she didn't like the taste and
it's like you know what I'll just go do
these things that make me happy and like
travel and be with my boyfriend and like
she'll always make money because she is
one of the biggest influencers but like
she doesn't need to
maybe she just doesn't want to work that
hard I don't know I not that but like
you're totally right there's something
going on with her
you know she's definitely pulled back
like when you think about you know how
much content she used to share
really before like the Kardashian days
and then she like blew up in on the
Kardashian and like it took her to
another level and she made a conscious
decision whether it had to do with her
family stuff or just a decision she came
to on her own she is not sharing what
she used to share she's not as public as
she used to be and she's relatively like
Off the Grid right so you can't be off
the grid and your brand is gonna
successfully a new brand that doesn't
it's not established like it's not going
to just stay at the top
when the brand revolves around a person
the person has to be a hundred percent
in and has to stay at the top in order
for the brand to be at the top and I
don't think she wants that no I don't
think she does either I don't think
she's even upset by this or a surprise
no me neither like I don't think she
cares yeah because she's caring about
something else right now I don't know
what that is I would I would love to
know but it seems like she's happy in
what she's doing she cares about her
peace yeah which I majorly respect
respect same because it's
it's a toxic world and it's like she
wasn't like Char like Charlie in the
sense that
Charlie was younger so she probably
wasn't exposed to some of the things
that Addison was exposed to when she
first got famous plus she had her family
around her to protect her and like I
think maybe Addison saw into the belly
of the Beast and was like no thank you
I'm good yeah but like some of the perks
of this life are amazing and she's
always like you know she's always on the
Amalfi Coast I feel like she's always
traveling and just being with her
boyfriend and like trying to find
happiness
I love that for her I really do I like
to item Beauty like I used a bunch of
their products it was cute it was
definitely like targeted for a younger
demo younger demos do not shop at
Sephora I think Addison's brand would be
like such a better fit at Ulta
um it's a lower price point it's more
accessible Sephora's like very
hoity-toity there's no reason Addison's
you know line should be sold in the same
store as Dior Beauty like that just is
not
she doesn't be next to Pat McGrath
yeah but what does Ulta not sell Dior
like they do but Ulta's just much more
of like everything is here everything
you need from the five dollar eyeliner
to the 50 yeah and Sephora is like very
tailored very refined you have to get in
and it's hard to get in like it's much
more of like an elite experience whereas
Ulta it's like for the masses you you
need something from from makeup wise
you're better more likely to find it at
Ulta is item exclusive to Sephora it was
yes so was it was like so Sephora has
this like brand incubator they like own
parts of the brands that launch in their
store like rare Beauty they own part of
uh I believe makeup by Mario is a
Sephora excuse now house labs and wasn't
Fenty Sephora exclusive
um maybe at one point but I think they
sell everywhere now so I'm not sure
I'm just Googling it most of the brands
and it's so smart on Sephora's behalf
like most of the brands because they can
make or break a brand based on where
they put you how many stores they put
you in so they have this thing where
like they will finance and and co-found
a brand with a celebrity or an
influencer and they'll co-own it
together and that's what they did with
rare beauty that has been I think
probably one of their most successful
launches same with makeup by Mario
that's what they did with Addison an
item it didn't work yeah and skincare by
Hiram and it's not always gonna work
it's not always going to work but like I
mean look at rare Beauty look at makeup
by Mario those are like literally two of
the biggest brands in makeup right now
and Sephora is at the center of it yeah
no I don't think it's a Sephora I think
it's a whole
pie and every piece has to carry its
weight
yeah
so
but also you know
these makeup brands are fickle and
fleeting you're at the top right now and
you could be floundering in a few years
so it's also just such an oversaturated
market like if you want to stay at the
top forever like you have to constantly
be doing the most you know yeah
which is why it's like
there are some brands that don't have to
resort to these gimmicks that are just
like good [ __ ] Mainstay like yeah like
the ogs the ogs yeah so they're probably
like looking at all these clowns who are
like in the circus and they're like
we're happy to not be there
right
yeah it's funny it'll be funny even like
a few years
all these celebrity influencer Brands
will come and go and like what we're
left with is the ones that were here
from the beginning benefit Nars Laura
Mercier
totally I but I think a few will like I
think at this point Fenty like Rihanna's
not even forward-facing like that is
just here to stay
no that's like the perfect example of
launching a brand off the back of a
celebrity or
um influencer and the brand totally
exists on its own
but Rihanna still being like the face of
it only helps tenfold agreed
are you ready for our next story
little young Hollywood news Austin
Butler is reacting to Kaio Gerber's ex
Jacob elordi also playing Elvis
Austin Butler is ready to pass the torch
to Elvis Presley well the Elvis Presley
torch to his girlfriend's ex Jacob lordy
the Elvis star who is arguably the
world's strongest committer to the bit
shot down any speculation that there's
bad blood between him and Jacob who will
be playing the king of rock and roll on
the big screen Butler told variety at
the Golden Globes that I wish him all
the best we haven't spoken but I hope he
has a great time Jacob will be playing
Elvis in the Priscilla Presley biopic
called Priscilla
okay so I we I feel like we've spoken
about how weird it is that literally in
the same year they're making another
Elvis biopic especially when like the
first one was so big and Blockbuster and
major like what's the point I don't
think I ever put together that it being
Jacob elordi like that they shared Kya
Gerber we did like they had that in
common I believe we did yeah
okay I just I guess I haven't like
consciously thought about it in a while
because it's like definitely weird and I
wonder if the interviewer like knew she
was asking this like hot button question
or if she just like want us you know
talking about the latest Elvis news yeah
probably both
yeah but it's crazy it's like just Kaya
Gerber in bent Elvis's where she
attracted to men who could play Elvis
I think she's attracted to men who could
play because only the biggest stars in
the world could play Elvis biggest stars
and like really traditionally like old
Hollywood glamor handsome is the vibe of
Elvis and like that's so Austin Butler
that's clearly like her type yeah
I mean whoever she dates next like could
be Elvis too
Elvis the mini-series even though like
with this you know award season upon us
we're getting like a lot of Kaya Gerber
and Austin Butler moments photos videos
like the video of him after he won the
Golden Globe like giving her the biggest
kiss and hug like it's it's literally
it's too much like it's so cute
it's cute
I don't know I'm still like justice for
Vanessa Hudgins yeah I'm just like
I don't know something about him
yeah I can't I can't shake that one
thing I read once
uh what I can't shake is like what in an
alternate reality if like he had blown
up in the way that he did you know
Nickelodeon star to Elvis you know he
was Irrelevant for so many years
literally I only remembered him as
Vanessa hudgens's boyfriend
if if he had you know had this moment
and had Vanessa by his side like
and not just kind of the way that I see
it is like dropping her for somebody
like you know younger and more famous
and more connected if he had stuck with
the girl who stuck with him I would have
had so much obsessed like it should be
Vanessa at the Golden Globes because
like Kaya Gerber will be there anyway
like Vanessa at the Oscars but it's not
like he left Vanessa for
Kaya there's a lot of time in between
them but I do feel like
the time from in which he like left
Vanessa and got the Elvis role which he
knew would change his life
like his fortunes changed and so all of
a sudden his life did too
no and like there's the clip that goes
around all the time of Vanessa being
asked on Live with Kelly and Ryan what
she thought about Austin after they
broke up being cast as Elvis and she was
so happy for him she's like I literally
have been manifesting this for him we
were in the car going somewhere on the
PCH we're in a convertible and an Elvis
song comes on and he started singing and
I literally said to him like you have to
play Elvis like I literally like
invented this idea and she was really
like genuinely happy for him I don't
know I just I can't help but think like
what those red carpet photos like what
we could be experiencing right now if
like you know the two Disney kids like
stuck together I agree
I feel like we're missing out on that it
should have been Vanessa's kiss
I love the content I love the Vanessa
kiss I mean I love the Kaya kiss like
and this is no slight Takaya this has
nothing to do with Kaya but I just can't
help but think what could have been yeah
no Kaya is fine she will be fine she's
literally like baby Thrice over plus
she's literally so we're just like she's
fine I'm not worried about her she's
fine no I agree like that that social
climbery thing you referenced earlier
this week like it's definitely something
there yeah it's just so sometimes like
my alarm Bells go off of course of
course our fifth and final story a
little daytime talk show news that I
think is going to upset my grandma
claired no insiders are buzzing that
Rachel Ray's daytime talk show is ending
oh I mean you know what all good things
must come to an end honestly and Rachel
Ray has been at the helm of like home
and cooking and daytime and she's had an
illustrious career maybe she's tired
this is not a failure
but the world will will not be as good
not confirmed but one Industry Source
speculated that her show is ending this
will be the last season another source
told paychecks they wouldn't be
surprised if the show went away because
it hasn't been doing well for a while
it's easy to forget that it's even on uh
she has been on for 17 Seasons now and
insiders also at the show are scoffing
at this and saying that the talk comes
up every year because the show is
renewed yearly in fact they're out there
renewing the show right now there's
never a decision until later in the
spring so
it's one of those you know you know
believe what you want to believe show
even if the show did end it wouldn't be
a failure by any means being on the air
for 17 years whether it was her decision
or the network decided not to renew
regardless it's such a an accomplishment
she really and and TV and daytime are so
you know on the downhill anyway like I
really probably wouldn't have much to do
with Rachel although I can't help but
imagine that the success of the Kelly
Clarkson show might have had an impact
on Rachel Ray I feel like they're very
similar like energy audiences and
audiences I mean they look alike but
their audiences I feel like are very you
know older female Middle America like
they love Kelly and they love Rachel Ray
and they like love to buy all of their
clothes you know yeah but unless they're
on at the same time like why can't we
watch both
no you can I just I just have to imagine
the success of her show made a dent in
ratings for Rachel right like people
getting their fix from Kelly I agree
with that
and Kelly has like an amazing social
team like they blow up on Tick Tock her
Clips go viral they're really kind of
doing the most like daytime is so
Antiquated and so old school and they're
very much bringing it into the 21st
century like Kelly Clarkson is killing
it with the guests everything I mean and
you really can't compete with Kelly
Oakey
you can't compete with the Kelly
Clarkson show there's nobody in daytime
doing more doing better and doing it you
know in a more stunning way a more
digitally forward way than Kelly yeah
she kills it she really does look at her
and honestly I I imagine that her
karaoke performance of happier oh no
what song is it you made me hate this
city what's happier than ever
oh okay
what that performance I think did for
her entire show cannot be over estimated
like I have seen that video posted on
social media no more than a thousand
times with millions and millions of
views I think it introduced Kelly to a
generation that had not been familiar
with you know Justin and Kelly and
American Idol they're alive I cannot
overstate the
impact that performance had on her show
honestly well you know what that
generation needs Kelly because she's a
breath of fresh air she's a positive
she's uplifting Queen she's been through
stuff and she's come out the other side
and she's never lost that Kelly smile
I don't know if you saw but Kelly
actually had Justin Guarini on the show
no I didn't see
I saw clips of the interview it was so
sweet like I literally could I was like
had tears in my eyes they were such good
friends during the uh the show and he
was so happy that she won and they had
this great career after you know the
movie and they were really the kind of
like this video for a while he was the
Dr Pepper guy
yeah I mean that was years and years
later but I'm talking about like
directly after the show like I don't
even think it mattered that that she won
and he didn't like they both really had
this moment after the show
um and it was so sweet and it was so
cool of Kelly to like have him on and I
can't recommend the interview enough it
was really beautiful that's gorgeous it
doesn't surprise me though Kelly just
giving back
to the community to everyone so true so
true do you want to have Justin Guarini
on the toast would that be a dream guest
I would love to it's sweet ones we
literally started the show with Kelly
and we ended the show with Kelly as we
do as often as we can you know and you
know what I never see from Jackie to
Kelly I never see comments less Kelly
Clarkson talk that's what I don't see
you're right they say less Kardashians
less worlds but nobody ever says all
right enough with the Kelly Clarkson
Because you want to know why she is
America's sweetheart [ __ ] that's why
she is she's a woman of the people
and actually speaking of I do believe
Chloe was also recently on um the Kelly
Clarkson show and they they appear to to
connect that's so cool but like do you
think Kelly gets invited to like those
dinners like those celeb star-studded
like
plus billionaires dinners you want to
know what I actually think she doesn't
um and I don't think that's a reflection
on Kelly I think Kelly is probably the
most normal famous person you'll ever
see in your life she has said like she
is obsessed with her level of Fame like
she has all these opportunities this
[ __ ] goes to Walmart nobody looks at
her like she has this like unreal level
of Fame where she's in millions of homes
but her life is relatively normal and
unaffected I think she still probably
does drop off and pick up she probably
as a nanny but like I think she
maintains this level of normalcy that is
jarring to other celebrities because
they don't so maybe they're and I don't
think like Kelly I don't think that they
can relate to the feeling of wanting
such normalcy like such normalcy like to
go to Walmart and not be recognized like
I they would be offended by that like
they say oh I just want one normal day
but they don't want like a whole ass
normal life like it's no you're right
and I think Kelly's entire career thus
far has been like
an act in balancing success and normalcy
and she's done it brilliantly and that's
why
hair two four we need the Kelly Clarkson
documentary how did she do it
so true and the things that she overcame
with her record label the many eras of
Kelly
give us the dog and you know who allies
you know who I want to hear from as a
commentator who like has their own
personal experience and just can share
what their thoughts on Kelly
John Legend Carrie Underwood
yeah because she's a similar to Kelly
but I want to know what Kelly did that
inspired Carrie
et cetera Etc so that's just a free idea
for the industry
I thought you were going to say John
Legend because there's that famous
moment on watch Happens Live where Kelly
is talking she was promoting her new
album which had a feature from John
Legend and she was talking about how she
wanted a feature and like literally
nobody in the music industry would get
on her Record She was like literally I
couldn't get arrested and John Legend
like showed up and was like I'll happily
do it and the song blew up and it was
like in this amazing story but if it
weren't for John Legend like literally
nobody would have wanted to be on on her
record morons and that's why the
industry is filled with morons morons
and that's why Addison left honestly
honestly it was that sort of elitism
and more honesty that sent Addison
straight to the Amalfi Coast
when did an Addison ex Kelly collab
that's what we need
Addison on the Clarkson show
Addison MCC Clarkson
uh we need a song collab we may you know
what literally Kelly has to do Kelly too
obsess to say you're obsessed with me so
I took a second and I said me too
I'm obsessed with me as much as you we
need more Addison music 100 literally I
need Addison to find what she loves in
this life aside from traveling and
ignoring us yeah and to do that what
about her acting oh my God she was so
good and she saw that she saw that movie
she was still getting she had a big deal
with Netflix and like what's next
Addison come back to us we're sorry
we're sorry for what we did she left it
all behind for the Amalfi Coast would
can you blame her no but we're sorry
Addison we won't do it again whatever it
was that we did to upset you I'm sure it
was terrible I'm sure what if someone
like drove Addison away like some nasty
big wig tried to take advantage of her
yeah let me know who it is because I'm
in town and I'll pull up in my Uber and
I'll go [ __ ] him up
and he'll have to apologize it's a He
he'll have to apologize to Addison
and bring her back and he will step down
and then Addison will get his job
controlling the studio
business woman moments bring back our
Addison
that is our show that was our final show
of the week I cannot thank you guys
enough for being patient with your West
Coast early on West Coast time but
starting next week we're back on Tuesday
we're back on our regular time I will be
back in New York Jax thanks for checking
and driving with me this week I really
appreciate it I love to shock and jive
with you
you do literally you do literally
literally thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe thumbs up
we're also available as podcasting we're
podcasting event so it's Spotify
to all the places we've listened podcast
find us the totally five star review
about our beautiful stunning and smart
we are hope you guys have it in Korea
[Music]
weekend don't forget to you know
celebrate the weekend alarm Free Living
we love you dearly we'll see you on
Tuesday bye